here's what would happen if Antarctica's
dormant volcanoes woke up
Antarctica's volcanoes are buried under
layers of ice more than four kilometers
thick in places if one was to erupt the
heat released would melt massive caverns
in the ice creating substantial amounts
of melt water from there the domino
effect would kick in in the case of
Antarctica multiple volcanic eruptions
could wake up over 100 other volcanoes
and destabilize the entire region if all
of Antarctica's ice melted it would
raise the global sea level by about 60
meters extensive flooding would push
millions of people from the coastline
but don't worry Antarctica's volcanoes
won't erupt all at once if they start to
wake up it would take decades for
anything substantial to happen so